welcome to the AI the future of us a
podcast Style video series that explores
the ways AI is shaping our feature and
how we can prepare for the changes that
Leia has I'm your host ferrat seconder
and today we are joined by Kate Wright
who is a senior director of product
management at Lucas and business
intelligence here at Google Cloud thank
you for being here today Kate
thank you for having me always fun to
have a chat yes looking forward to it so
I would like to get some background on
your expertise so could you please tell
us about below your background and you
know expertise in the field though bi
and AI really
yeah of course I I admit I've been in
this business intelligence field for an
incredibly long time
um I almost don't want to own to the
numbers but if it's sort of a 20-year
kind of Mark
um in you know versions of business
intelligence and data and analytics
um you know through a variety of
companies business objects sap
um Tableau and Salesforce and of course
now here at Google and
um you know with respect to specifically
the AI side of it you know we've seen AI
come to the business intelligence field
sort of eight or nine years ago with
force and so I got the opportunity to
really spend some time with some of the
classical ml techniques things like
regression and classification and time
series forecasting as we were building
them into the business intelligence
products to sort of allow those um allow
the business users to have access to
those things without really having to
understand them you know in the form of
automatically creating reports and and
you know scoring data and understanding
key influencers
um and then I you know I kind of
continued on that to to work on topics
where we would take take some of those
and I'll models and operationalize them
into applications because of course I
was working at Salesforce and sap
Enterprise application companies and
it's all great to do something once but
it's really important it becomes a lot
more powerful when you put it in the
operational workflow for end users and
so quite a lot of expertise in sort of
the classical ml techniques and I've
also spent some time building natural
language query systems as well and of
course you know that is like you know
the topic of the moment as we've seen
natural language query systems and chat
systems you know become a totally
different Beast with the onset of llms
and so you know obviously there's some
of that happening now but but I also
have spent a couple of years doing that
in you know the previous world where the
technology had a different set of
ceilings yeah
that that's amazing right and then
seeing all that Evolution I don't want
to call it Revolution but the
evolutional AI coming in really changing
how you know things are impacting and
but how did you you know go if you go
back what made you to get interested in
AI as well in the first place and then
what is the thing that you find the most
fascinating about it as well
you know it's um
like business intelligence is it has
always historically been about like
what's going on or what happens
um and then why but the reality is you
ask those questions so that you can do
something in the future and so the
reason we brought it in to bi and you
know was to be able to answer answer
like well what do you do about it kind
of questions and what really has
fascinated me is this difference between
what is factual which is like what
happened and what is approximated or
predicted what might happen and you know
I've spent quite a bit of time working
with users through as we're working
through kind of building these
capabilities into products and working
on like how do you help them trust and
understand that the data is no longer
accurate the same way and you actually
have to have to look at the data
differently
um and it might not be consistent
day-to-day what what is going to happen
tomorrow and like all those concepts are
really difficult for for users to get
their heads around and so that's been
something that's super fascinated me is
really like that human element of
working with AI outputs and the trust
associated with it
um like again something that is you know
very dynamic in today's world
and I I really like the way that you put
it right so bi is exactly more factual
traditionally with everything that you
do data analytics and then user is more
involved at the beginning of it but the
AI is more statistical right so you
might not get the exact output that you
might be looking for and you are
involved more towards the end to analyze
the results and make sure that they are
the right results as well and that
that's awesome way of putting a tenure
right so and with that what are the key
AI developments that you witnessed
during your career that has been
spanning for the past 20 plus years
because it does feel like one of those
moments it's like sort of you know you
know you have a child and you're like
well there are the before times and
there are the now times and your life is
so different right and it's very
difficult to think about the evolutions
that I saw for like 18 19 years and then
now and so you know I saw an improvement
on accessibility like we started to see
some of these AI techniques get into the
hands of more you know Advanced analysts
and things like citizen data science has
come in and so accessibility has
improved but it hasn't been a huge step
function I would say in the last night
you know that that four before the
before times
um and we've also seen improvements just
from the perspective of scale you know
with gpus coming in and again like it's
it sort of had it sort of had been
improving and I I sort of would say that
it was you know linear to accelerating
um and now it's like it's like a whole
different game right um and you see
those those scale Concepts the
accessibility concepts of some of these
techniques are suddenly you know I think
this is this is the explosion we're
excited about
um and so that's the piece that that you
know I guess I haven't yet fully
witnessed it um but I I would say those
same kernels
um you know have been have been
occurring for quite some time it's just
that they were occurring with a
incremental technology set of
improvements rather than an exponential
set of Technology improvements
um yeah
and I agree right and we are very lucky
to be just at the heart of this you know
Evolution as well again uh you know and
I really find it evolutionary as well
and but let's look at a little bit of
the challenges because uh you know and
looking I would like to explore a little
bit you know your views around Bridging
the Gap between you know bi and data
analytics together with machine learning
because there are you know other laps
that we see traditionally in two
separate disciplines right business
intelligence and data analytics is
usually in one place and machine
learning in another place in most of the
organizations how do you recycle that
yeah that's it's a great question and
it's something that
I I don't know that it's yet changing
like that's again it gets to the
interesting parts of like the human
dynamics and the organizational dynamics
that come into play outside of
Technology
um
it's uh
you know one of the things that I have
witnessed again and again and I think
I'm witnessing it now is it's much
easier for us all to think of the
opportunity incrementally like you know
whether it's whether it's llms or
whether it's AI in general a lot of
business cases I've talked to
organizations about or like how can we
just reduce costs like this small amount
and it's it's really challenging for
people to think about the actual
potential use cases they could use
um and this is where I think the actual
problem comes in it's less about like an
animal department and a bi department
but it's what we see when we kind of
apply some of these capabilities and put
them into bi tools is that the people
using the eye tools do not understand
the fundamentals of ML and so they don't
know they it's like it's the classic I
don't know what I don't know problem and
so you know the easy example I like to
give is uh when you're preparing data to
run machine learning on it the data set
tends to look very different and you
need to engineer the data set in order
to get good results and time and time
again we saw this problem where people
would just take any old data set they
already have typically aggregated data
and they would be like well why aren't I
getting you know predictions on this why
aren't I getting key influencers you
know sort of from that bi group and so
you did really end up relying on these
other experts in these other places of
the organization
um and you know and just putting the
tools in front of people wasn't enough
and so you know I I'm hopeful that
because we are making this much much
easier you know and because I you know I
believe that you know Technologies like
llms will will help you know be able to
walk that same business analyst through
the steps of preparing data to be able
to do the right kind of prediction that
they want to do you know if they ask the
right set of questions and if we guide
them through the right set of questions
you know we can kind of avoid that
problem where you have to go to this
expert community in order to do some of
those things at least the low hanging
fruit but again today that that problem
is is very much a human skills and
understanding problem and you know
people not really being incentivized to
go after what they don't know and that
bigger opportunity that exists
um and again I still see that today I so
in the conversations with llms people
are I think a lot of customers are still
you know thinking incrementally and
thinking about how they can you know
really just tune and improve their
business rather than you know disrupt it
and you know these bigger opportunities
um and so I think that's the piece that
I as I'm looking at these two two
disciplines and these two groups of
people
um I'm hopeful that we can kind of use
llms to bridge some of that expertise
Gap
um rather than having you know the ml
team have to necessarily support
everyone which is sort of I don't see
that problem improving unfortunately
um because it's just too vast right the
opportunity for ML is too fast for The
Limited set of people who really
understand it to be able to address it
yes and I agree and and I think it is a
little bit of a change management within
the organizations to have this little
bit you know uh different type of
mindset as well and also I think you are
absolutely right that AI teams shouldn't
be the bottleneck eventually that I
think we can you know close that Gap a
little bit as well
so and with that
with that then you alluded a little bit
into that how do you see bi with llam in
mind evolving in the next few years as
well
yeah business intelligence is an
interesting industry because the last
maybe eight years or so we've been
really aggressively putting AI into our
tooling
um and under the you know the
description of augmented business
intelligence or augmented analytics and
you know it's come in the form of a
variety of things right I mentioned key
influencers and sort of these classic ml
techniques natural language query is is
another one and automated Insight is
kind of like that third Mega category
and they're of course there are of
course others um and so that means that
what we've been talking about in the
business intelligence industry is this
huge huge opportunity around you know
giving users the ability to ask
questions on data and get answers and
really improving the accessibility of
information to more people we've been
talking about that for a long time and I
think what we found was that the
technology ceiling has kind of prevented
us from being able to really make that a
reality and of course some of the
organizational concerns like there was a
lot of work required for organizations
to put this into place well and then
when they did the user experience didn't
really deliver the promise and so you
know I think what it's interesting for
the business intelligence industry is
it's really possible that now we're at
the point where we can actually go and
make these these promises a reality as
far as you know making giving the
ability for more people to have insights
at their fingertips to be able to ask
questions and be guided to get answers
and I think the other piece of it is
just we should be able to automate a ton
of manual efforts so things around like
data preparation things around formula
writing
um you know creation of charts uh you
know it takes an incredible amount of
clicks and and tunes and knobs today to
set up set up a chart that looks good
right from a styling perspective from a
number formatting perspective from like
how you want the axes to be aligned in
the legend you know we should be able to
make things look good and be a best best
fit like a lot faster we should be able
to give people 90 of the way they are a
lot more and so I see sort of this
accessibility theme and then this kind
of automation theme that really I think
are going to come and hit business
intelligence and sort of deliver on some
of this opportunity that we've been
talking about for some time
yes and I'll keep that in mind
accessibility and Automation and I think
do you have spots on that as well and if
you look at them a little bit on the
challenges specifically on the
generative AI uh on on the you know bi
ecosystem right so it is sweat how do
you see that it is currently being used
and how do you see you know what value
data is going to bring to organization
so I'm really asking two questions in
one in a sense as well
yeah I mean we you know some of the
challenges we have been seeing for some
time I think are going to manifest
themselves even worse in the Gen AI
world right and so if you look if you
look at what has happened business
intelligence has has had this huge boom
of self-service you know democratization
of information but when we talk about
that we've really democratized it to
data people who sit outside of I.T not
to non-data people and so you have this
huge group of
um of analysts and and you know again
sort of business analysts working with
these tools and a huge amount of
artifacts and data sets that are
fragmented that are inconsistent across
each other and that's where really most
of the business logic and the
intelligence lives is in these
individual reports and these individual
you know extracts and cubes of data
inside these these bi tools and these
self-service tools and the challenge is
going to be that the opportunity for us
with Gen AI is to really really make
sure that we are able to give people
answers quickly but in order to do that
we have to have a trusted resilient set
of information to operate on and it's
very unlikely in the world where you
have three different dashboards that do
the same thing and calculate stuff
differently that we're going to be able
to get those answers right and so I
think this this is one of the challenges
we have today that we have to figure out
how we really Implement properly and
that organizations Implement properly is
getting to that trusted Enterprise data
it will become an even bigger problem
and an even bigger opportunity for us to
deliver with Gen AI you know we're
starting to see llms in the industry
with with again formula writing with
chart Generation
Um you know with some data prep and
things like that and again with
improving the natural language query
systems that we've had for some time but
I think it's still really early and in
most cases we're still seeing that in
the context of an existing dashboard
right and so if I send you a dashboard
it's great that you can ask a question
in the context of the data that was
extracted with that but it's also very
likely that you have a question that's
related on data that was not extracted
at the time the analyst thought about it
and then also is is the answer going to
be right is is anybody there curating to
make sure that it's consistent and so I
think there's this there's this piece
where we're the demos are starting to
look good but as far as them really
being you know powerfully meaningful I
think we're still not quite there yet
and I think that becomes a you know the
data problem right so it will be as good
as the data that you are feeding into
the system at the end of the day and
generally is supporting that a little
bit but with the you know with the with
the human element still and I think
that's the key and that's where for
organizations the opportunity lies is
like again back to the human right back
to the ease of use being radically
improved for so many more people and if
they can get value very quickly because
the ease of use is so improved then the
organizations can actually use data you
know to make decisions as you know as as
the dream says right and and this is
where you know being able to do that
repeatedly on trusted information you
know that is where the value comes in
for the organization and so you have you
know ease of use more people accessing
it more people working together to make
decisions on trusted data you know that
that is the value because they should be
able to really have people actually be
on top of their business goals
um which I think today not enough of us
are confident that we really understand
what's going on yes totally agree then I
think the value will be added as you say
by bringing new folks into the game but
also uh using the more expensive and
very capable folks you more efficiently
as well by automating some of the tasks
that they have been doing that's right
and and looking ahead with the with AI
in business intelligence what do you
believe the most exciting potential
application of AI and gen AI we are yet
to see as well yeah it's um I think I
I'm excited for two things right I I I'm
excited about the you know applications
that come in when
anybody can kind of write code and it's
not like you know you see you sort of
seeing this start to happen now where
it's like you're asking a system to go
do something and rather than it knowing
how to do that it's actually calling out
and actually scripting the you know how
it's going to get that answer for you
which you know creates kind of this
infinite quantity of possibilities and
so we're not necessarily as tied to the
functionality of any specific
application but it just it again brings
so much power to so many people and so I
think in the bi context we don't really
know what those what that possibility is
yet but but that's huge and it also
makes you know the the more code
addressable the architectures are that
we're working with and the more
developer friendly they are of course
you know that tends to help us because
they can be addressed by apis right and
so I think there's there's exciting
potential there and the other piece like
for me I make so many slides and I I end
up telling stories as part of my job so
often and I am a terrible visual
designer and I you know and I I don't
make a lot of dashboards or I don't make
a lot of visual reports but I do you
know again I storytell and I storytell
with data often and I am so ready for
these systems to become my visual
designer in my pocket and make things
beautiful for me
um and I think that's the other thing is
the creative act aspects that you know
can bring that to some of us who maybe
don't have that so naturally
um and make that accessible I think is
also really exciting
um and again like you know help help me
do this but help me write it as a
limerick so that when I'm engaging my
team you know I can tell tell them a
story about how we had a great quarter
but I can do it in a funny way right but
there's so many opportunities around
some of that that honestly gets me
excited and we haven't really even
touched yet
and I agree and it gives us the ability
to extend our you know what we have in
our mind will be more easily reflected
within the charts and everything else as
well and and my last question is around
what advice would you give to individual
and business individuals and the
businesses to prepare for the future
which AI is definitely going to play an
even more significant role right and and
we hear a lot of a lot of horror stories
everyone is going to lose the air jobs
and robots are going to take over and
everything else as well what's your
views
those are two loaded questions I you
know for as far as advice I I would I'd
focus on like two things one is yeah
skills and training I think it also
helps us all have more confidence as
humans on what's really happening if we
understand it better so making sure the
general population understands ml
Concepts understands like you know the
more technical people understand a
little bit of python
um and that we all you know understand a
little bit about prompt writing like you
know just again those those Basics like
if you think about
um you know how we all have to be
upskilled on Fishing Concepts and you
know anybody who works in the Enterprise
right it's not that we're all Security
Experts but we know the basics and you
know that helps keeps us safe and I
would say you know feeling like you
understand your role in this new
universe is helpful if you understand
the technology a little better and so
that kind of training I think honestly
should go to like the general populace I
haven't quite figured out how to educate
my nine-year-old yet but but I'm working
on it
um and then I would also say that that
is what leads into your second question
right is like is like how do we how do
we think about a world where so many
things will get automated
um and and I think that's what where you
know nobody can predict the future but I
think that's this is our opportunity to
to just reframe how our jobs might
evolve where it might be less about you
know turning those knobs and finding
those 17 clicks inside the bi tool and
instead like writing really great
prompts and engaging in systems that can
extend those tools for you
um and leaning on you know how how you
can you know what what part of your job
you can be amazing at that's that 10
that that really matters because these
are all going to be assist human
assisted systems right and so I I'm
pretty confident that that we have a lot
of humans that are still going to be
involved in the workforce but um but I
do think it would help us all to to
understand a bit what that might look
like by just kind of feeling confident
getting skilled up
I agree with you and I think they as you
say foundations will be the key if you
define foundations you'll be able to
leverage these tools better in fact this
was reflected by some research been done
in MIT which was published last month as
well which I was reading uh you know
coming into that and the economies are
going to grow as a result of this right
and shrinking so it is going to generate
even more roles for everyone
foreign
it has been incredibly insightful to
hear your thoughts and on the impact and
effective use of the AI we look forward
to seeing how AI will continue to shape
the world around us and hope our viewers
will be inspired to embrace its
potential and opportunities thank you
very much indeed thank you so much for
having me
figure it out together
foreign